there are many ways to approach this
someone asked you first
in there a particular method you won't
be showing you around back because it
changes yeah it can be done by cases but
it is hard and it's also I find it's a
bit like I'm doing things by cases is
sometimes a little bit like following
instructions on an on a recipe you can
follow them but you don't necessarily
know why you're doing what you're doing
you're just sort of going through the
motions and then crossing your fingers
that acting out at the end of a baked
cake will come out okay you're like oh I
imagine it degrees once baking country
this honorary but feel nothing
we're asking if I gives you much bigger
or literally does your bigger picture so
learn how to go this okay so I'm going
to take photographs so let's just bring
that part of the question down first
okay I need to consider this and this
and then I'm going to come on okay so
draw other I think the axes and what I'm
going to do is if the question were part
a graph I would have to take quite a lot
of attention to the specifics of the
graph itself because the question is
grab however it because you just solve
this and obviously graph as a tool the
graph doesn't have the in beautiful rain
is you know if this is a rule of us so
it just has to be good enough so then
you can use it as a guide to solve the
question so spatula color one piece at a
time I'm going to think about this and
then this
so X minus to forget at the absolute
value per second what does y equals
exponent 2
like just what it dispenses - cute yeah
and energy yeah it's a great one so I
have that visual in my mind I have it
here you love yoga oh isn't it okay so
it's we're teaching right
oh I you'll notice I haven't drawn the
bottom of the accidents you know what
causes not only the as today I'm adding
of the guidance if you add two things
that are positive you get something off
it's positive so that's why I'm going
toward the bottom however you want do
something like this one now okay if that
would like thinking in tune and then off
you go integrated we'll get one okay so
I'm going to be reaching and I'm going
to draw part of it right now that is the
only part that I've drawn because of the
positive part the rest of it is
irrelevant
okay what does happen to the rest of its
mountains on the surface very good so
this and this is important I've got I've
got two branches right so I'm going to
label the branches as they are this part
here is why it was X minus two
what's the other part why was a minor a
negative your item hood by the way it's
fine I'm just going to write you my next
because I'm maybe in that box okay but
it is valid to say negative x plus two
cool now I've got the other part as the
value of 2x plus 1 what you tell me that
we're too good so now that I have actual
values on my graph what do you desire
you again is working through it was
there too and it reflected up to - okay
stop that - then just for my own sake
I'm going to put one in a reasonable
spot okay so this one so it crosses the
axis there and you told me it was here
so it's going to do something like this
you go that
and of course it's a reflected research
now we go to sleep I'm feeling like I'm
a bit of a sticker but you really get
good enough that I do unity could not -
Jake I'm okay
now again this pie has two marches so
you've got the two x plus one branch and
what's your lunch on my one line
interest of you leave one lives to all
we know they're both negative both
[ __ ] is the reason why disharmonic
ignorance yeah Thank You spot this is in
fact mine into X minus one shouldn't
know that alright so now we want to
think about what this thing is going to
look like now I already know a lot of
places where some of these two graphs
going to go through for instance
coincidentally I got to repeat numbers
down coincidentally the y-intercept of
both graphs together is going to be 1
plus 2 which is that point really
important to be because it's the battery
you can see them right there going to be
two to the left of this spot over here
but it has one to the left of your
engine is zero this is negative three
negative heart because remember it's
called random - so if you can imagine
trying going here with advised everyone
that's hard and that's 1 so 1 divided by
1/2 is
took misery so to the left of this
you're going to have these two guys
together all right I'm going to go up
right to here roughly now how many I
look at this I'm just
yes yes that's what I expected
you're going to have a line that really
really state we're serving like balances
so it outfit so the negative part
yep yep how do I get it where they come
from is just goes a bit so I can think
of it in terms of grant that's what way
to think about it another way to think
about it is it is the junction where
this bridge turns into this bridge yeah
agreement and the check that the
junction is is they think positive or is
it negative right it changes exactly
when it's 0 so I can do this okay so
that's not working how do you can move
it up and then like get one yeah yeah
okay so at this point here the gray
graph is zero and then I'm adding zero
to something else
I don't know something else's but Europe
or something will be there something
here right
something just a few between two and
three okay
the oxidizer it could be offset is right
off the I guess absolutely kills and how
would you do that
I do you want me to do that as a
separate question yeah for now so I can
sort of interest what you the skillet
even that question even within this
question I'll show you what I mean
what have I got here okay this line is
really really to speak because you've
got this decreasing line or even to
write this decreasing line is decreasing
line so employed decrease is really
really decreasing I can start at find
out how much T is decreasing by looking
into Bobby's and adding it together
equations right it's going to be and
what's that what's the coefficient of x
it will be negative 3 right negative 2
here negative 1 what about their
continent to negative 1 that's plus 1
okay so that's the part that's the
equation that mint or branch okay
all right that was that looking to the
left of them they're on the right all
the way up until here in this region you
they've already shown you doing same
thing green line and do the same thing
so what I know what's happening in
between what's this dad - very good
so between negative half and two you've
got this line that's going down you have
zero plot this zero pot this whatever
this is southern Europe on to this is
just and in between you've got a point
here we already know the y-intercept
another point these are all two straight
lines the add straight lines you get
more straight line so this is the big
Detroit normal there anything in between
during your evaluation it's always a
straight line yeah that's right um I
guess um what if your function is
another linear functions the way we
would say okay all right now again we
can work out the equation of this middle
part how we're going to do it as the
decreasing branch Reuther yeah creasing
branch very good
so this originally created bridges to
minus X but this green increasing wages
to expose one so why are you going to be
equal to just collect the lighthouse for
X perfect and you can build extra
stickers look it goes through three yeah
we already posted out before and parade
of negative one rating of two that
leaves you the greater than one account
okay now watch this see how I've been
carefully constructing the engineer
working on what the equation is under
the drop this did and then I don't give
a rip what equations mean this is one of
great things about model your
communications because once you draw the
picture you know these
how why because they're both get free
I'm already about three right I already
went about three here so I don't care I
mean I can't work at this situation what
identity to touch it never ever okay or
if you just do stuff is happy to eat
here okay so it's enough of a grant to
do this I need to work out the part that
are about three there's only actually
small confirmatory right party that's
been done right
so from here upwards is good and then
from here I was this also group right
now conveniently this legs of the wider
center right so that's where X equal
zero so this is just going to be X is
greater than or equal to 0 Delta W
always okay this one is it a trickier
tournament work down the slot I didn't
have the substitution I know what the Y
value is all he are in exam three right
and I know what the equation is mine is
mine 3x plus one so I'm going to say
minus three X plus one
well wait is that equal to three and the
answer is too heavily with negative two
that looked like negative two-thirds
yeah yeah look remember that when I
figured it off just a left perfect
so this is X is less than or equal to
180
maybe that's your the trip I've double
liquid so now I can say this is true
when X is less than negative 3 or X is
greater than or equal zero while it or
not it because look enjoy because counts
yeah there's no box there isn't any dumb
one
there is these bunnies at the same time
you can be wanting to be the other which
is great but no but I did my thing in
what I aim to the first thing animal
some rocks because I didn't have an -
all and next lecture yeah well sometimes
yeah you see you see this is one of the
super powers of mathematics which is is
a two-edged sword in that bags there's
no westwards is always it simple a
simple character changes everything
so therefore a word written as so
economy makes things faster more
efficient and more dangerous when you
meet other things so if you were to do
this by in two cases okay
still doable I mean that wasn't that
wasn't quick either but cases is longer
I made up doing work that ends up being
redundant because you can't tell you
what no picture info me and then you get
the ayaats and so why I do that okay so
this is the way that I think is
definitely graphing is always useful
seven three months